Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Let's Play Slender :The Nine Pages
Okay, this is a game that was released recently in the Slender Legend
and I have no idea what it is about other than
there are nine pages instead of eight.
It's not an official sequel to Slender: The Eight Pages by Mr. Parsec Productions.
Eh, aaaaah!
I don't know what that was.
Freaky though.
Anyway let's get right into it.
I guess survival mode it is.
I have no other thing to do.
An my- oh you've got to be kidding me.
My mouse is once again outside of the game.
Good God. I hate it when that happens in games.
What I mean by that is that if I scroll too far to the left or right
my mouse pops out of the game so I've just got to make sure...
That I don't click outside or I will Alt+Tab.
I hate that in games.
It's just a small thing but it's important
for people with dual monitors like me.
It's just an added thing of difficulty.
Okay. So anyway, I'm assuming that this is going to be very Slender-like
in that there is going to be Slender in it.
Already saw that painting of him.
[Heavy breathing]
Oh that's me. Oh okay. I thought there was like going to be
Oh hello. I can move these boxes.
This is made on the Unity engine, by the way. Same as most of the other Slender games.
Oh oooh. Physics-based boxes.
Usually everything in these games are just static objects.
That is so amazing.
Best Slender game ever!
Alright let's try this again.
Even The Arrival didn't have physics-based anything.
Just kinda curious what I'm looking for.
I mean, I know I'm looking for pages.
Oh good. At least I can use things with E and I don't have to click.
That means I don't have to worry about the mouse being outside the game.
Hello?
Anybody? No pages.
Haven't found anything yet.
I mean if there are nine and I haven't found anything.
That means I might be here for a while.
Sprinting.
What's up with you boxes?
Damn physics boxes.
Duh!
Anything under there?
Secrets?
Nope, nothing okay.
Carrying on.
I obviously don't know the layout of the map or anything like that
so I have no idea what I'm looking for or why I'm looking for it
or what I'm doing.
Hey, it's my slendy buddy again.
Good for him.
He's so- ah ha!
"He has no eyes."
Yes, this is very true-aaah!
Well, that was a bit soon, doncha think?
Jesus Slendy, give me a chance.
Holy balls!
Ef off.
Okay.
Hey!
Aaaaaaaah!
Good God!
What am I doing?
It's not fair!
He's moving, he's a slidey slippery devil.
Turn around in a circle.
If I spin around three times and click my heals-
Aaaaaaah!
Aaah no!
No you don't fuck you!
Good, go to Hell!
Go to Hell you bastard.
Go to Hell!
Don't know how I managed to slip by him but I did.
Good God.
Go away.
Ah-ha page number two.
I'm on page- "I can't hide."
I mean, I'm trying to hide.
He seems to be following me everywhere I go
so I don't really have a chance to hide.
That guy is an a-hole.
Capital "A"-hole.
Two pages in close proximity.
Good, cause otherwise I would be screwed for life.
See quite a few rooms in here.
Hey look is that a key?
Why do I have a key?
Why is there a key, what's with these cabinets?
There better not be anything in these cabinets because I may
not be able to open all of them.
Oh, where is he?
Oooouuuuh, where is he?
I don't wanna know. I don't wanna know.
Oh God, it's like a maze in here, oh balls.
Page was just- why are there these same paintings of Slendyman?
I mean, there are more, there are other pages, or paintings.
Oh God it's like a friggin'-
Aaah! Aaaah!
Close it! Close the door!
I wonder if that was because I got the key.
"He will eat you."
Well that doesn't seem very Slender-like.
He will eat you.
Hi- aaaaaah! God damnit.
Oh!
God dammnit.
Oh God.
I wasn't ready for that. I wasn't- oh oh.
Okay.
You weren't there before.
Oh ah, gah, that wasn't right.
Oh that wasn't right.
What the hell happened?
How did he get me?
I don't know.
Let's try it again. Because I can't make a video too short.
That'd just be silly.
Oh God, that was like horrible.
That was so bad.
Oh man, I do- I do not feel good.
Hey wait this is close to where I was.
Haha, I need a key? I know where the key is, but why would I want it?
That's probably the ninth page, oh God dammnit.
Oh balls.
That was so bad.
Okay, alright, [babbling].
Oh good yeah.
It looks like the pages are in the same places.
Oh man. This game
This game, I tells ya, I tells ya it's not good man.
Okay, maybe they're not in the same places because there wasn't
one there before.
But there is one there now.
Hoo-ooly balls. The key is not there either so-
Aaa-yaayaa!
Where are-is ya?
Where is you at?
Don't be a douche.
Ah-ya-jajaja!
Noooooooooo!
I refuse.
I must- maybe I should have waited for that door last because
it seemed like that one was insta-death.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna get the door last.
[Nervous laughter]
Light, save me.
Save me, light. Save me!
Ah, come on!
I need nine pages?!
Aaah, gahh! Don't look at him!
So that's what I'm supposed to do:
I'm supposed to get the one in the key room last and then
sprint to the door.
Aaah, bu- fu!
Okay, if I look this way...and then run past you!
Oh my God that worked!
I can't believe that worked!
Holy balls!
Why did that work?
And why is it such a frikkin' maze in here?
Yeeeahh!
Oh God it's j- it's the worse maze ever.
This is not happy fun times.
I did not expect this particular slender game to be this scary.
"I'm not alone." I am most certainly alone.
Aaaah! Jesus balls!
Holy fuck!
Ohhhh!
Oh, come on!
He's in the damn- oh no he's not.
[Nearly crying]
You gotta stop it game.
Gotta stop it man.
[Mumbling]
[Nearly crying]
I don't wanna play.
I hate my chosen profession.
Okay, just need to be careful not to go in a circle because...
Okay, that's where I started and if I go right here I can
get some more pages before I loop back around the hallway.
If I go to the end of the hallway here, then loop back maybe I'll
be little better.
I just wanna go home, cuddle under a blanket or something.
This is not...not what I had in mind when I fired this game up.
Okay, there's the key.
Okay, gah, give me the key.
Aaaaaaaaah!
Fuuuuuuuuuuuuuuck!
He moved when I wasn't looking. Sonuvabich!
I hate the way this one slides!
Oh, this isn't a bad place.
Behind me!
Oh fuck...
Aaah! Balls!
Oh man.
Oh fuck, okay I just gotta...
AAAAAH NO!
HooOOOooly balls. Aaaah!
Gowaygowaygowaygowaygowaygoway!
[Incomprehensible screaming]
Jesus Christ that...
[Nearly crying]
I don't wanna play.
I wanna go home.
I wanna marvel at the physics-based boxes again.
That was more- that was more better than what's happening now.
Come on! Openopenopenopenopen.
Ah-ha!
"He will carry you?" I don't know what that said.
"Eat you" probably.
I'm abusing the sprint button. I should not be sprinting this much.
I should not be sprinting this much.
Okay, I think I've got all the pages here I can go out in the hallway again and
just go, yes, it's okay, it's okay.
Just go in here, go in there, and...
You're almost out of pages.
Okay, so, that's the hallway I came in I think.
I think, maybe.
Maybe I don't know.
Where's Slendy, he's not here anymore. He was here, like
around every corner [mumbling].
Oh yeah, I came in here.
Don't go that way.
[Scared mumbling]
I didn't even see him.
I did not even see him. I don't know.
I didn't see him.
Oh, come on!
Oh good there's a page back here.
"You can't hide." I can behind these physics-based boxes.
Okay, that's seven and I just need to find one more and then
open the door, get on the floor, everybody do the dinosaur.
And then I can go home and DIE in a fire.
Aaah, aaah! There's the last one. Before the page in the LOCKED ROOM!
I think I can get through here through here's of- No I cannot!
I cannot!
Oh God just go, just go, go go go!
Heart beating. Just need the one in the door.
And then I can go out! And then I win!
Don't kill me.
I'm too young to die!
Sprint, sprint, sprint!
Okay, save my sprint for when I leave the room with the locked page in it.
Aaaaaah!
No, no, no, no!
Gimme! Gimme! Gimme gimme!
Gimme outta here!
"Leave this place"? I'm leaving!
I'm out, I'm gone!
I'm so gone. Away! I'm leaving!
Go, don't kill me!
Don't kill me, bre! Don't kill me bro!
Yeeeeeeaaaaaaaaaaah!
[Nearly crying]
[Mumbling]
Okay.
That was probably the scariest Slender game I ever played in my life.
I'm not exaggerating.
I have never been more scared playing any game than that game.
Okay, so, anyway get ready for another game title of "scariest game ever."
I know I've got a few.
But each one takes a new title.
I wanna go home and cry, cry in my bed while hugging a teddy bear.
So, try it for yourself. Link is in the description below.
Thank you all so much watching. Click the annotation for more videos that
I've done and, as always, I will see you, in the next video.
Bye bye.
[Outro music]